to me marketing's about values this is a
very complicated world it's a very noisy
world and we're not going to get a
chance to get people to remember much
about us no company is and so we have to
be really clear on what we want them to
know about us now Apple fortunately is
one of the half-a-dozen best brands in
the whole world right up there with Nike
Disney Coke Sony it is one of the
Great's of the grapes not just in this
country but all around the globe and but
but even a great brand needs investment
and caring if it's going to retain its
relevance and vitality and the Apple
brand has clearly suffered from neglect
in this area in the last few years and
we need to bring it back the way to do
that is not to talk about speeds and
fees it's not to talk about myths and
magazines it's not to talk about why
you're better than Windows the dairy
industry tried for 20 years to convince
you that milk was good for you it's a
lie but they try it anyway and the sales
were going like this and then they tried
got milk and the sales are going like
this got milk the thing to talk about
apartment but that focus is on the
absence of the product
but-but-but the best example of all and
and one of the greatest jobs of of
marketing and though if the universe has
ever seen as Nike remember Nike sells a
commodity they sell shoes and yet when
you think of Nike you feel something
different than a shoe company and their
ads as you know they don't ever talk
about the product they don't ever tell
you about their soils and why they're
better than Reebok their souls
where's Nike doing their advertising
they they honor great athletes and they
honor great athletics that's who they
are that's what they are about Apple
spends a fortune on advertising you'd
never know it you never know so when I
got here we Apple just fired their
agency we're doing a competition with 23
agencies that you know for years
remember pick one and we blew that up
and we we hired Shaddai the ad agency
that I was fortunate enough to work with
years ago we created some award-winning
work including the commercial voted the
best dad ever made 1984 by advertising
professionals and we started working
about eight weeks ago and what we the
question they asked was our customers
want to know who is Apple and what is it
that we stand for where do we fit in
this world and what we're about isn't
making boxes for people to get their job
done although we do that well we do that
better than almost anybody in some cases
but apples about something more than
that Apple at the core its core values
is that we believe that people with
passion can change the world for the
better that's what we believe and we've
had the opportunity to work with people
like that we've had an opportunity work
with people like me with software
developers with customers who have done
it in some big in some small ways and we
believe that in this world people can
change it for the better and that those
people that are crazy enough to think
they can change the world are the ones
that actually do and so what we're going
to do in our first brand marketing
campaign in several years is to is to
get back to that core value a lot of
things have changed the markets a
totally different place than it was a
decade ago and apples totally different
in Apple's place in it it's totally
different and believe me the products
and the distribution strategies in
manufacturing are totally different and
we understand that the values and core
values those things shouldn't change the
things that Apple believed in at its
core are the same things that Apple
really stands for today and so we wanted
to find a way to communicate this and
what we have is something that I am I'm
very moved by it honors those people who
have changed the world
some of them are living some of them are
but the ones that aren't as you'll see
you know
[Music]
and the theme of the campaign is think
difference there's the people honoring
the people who think difference and who
knew this world forward and it's it is
what we are about it touches the soil of
this company so I've never had war with
and I hope that you feel the same way
about it I do years to the crazy ones
The Misfits rebels troublemakers round
pegs in the square holes
once you see things
they're not found the rules and they
have no respect in the status quo you
can quote them disagree with them
glorify or vilify them about the only
thing you can't do
[Music]
they change the human race forward
and while some may see them as the crazy
ones we see genius because the people
who are crazy enough to think they can
change the world
[Music]
you